[Musique]
pour Ava c'est l'heure de la sieste
comme tous les nouveaux parents victoire
et Matteo ont dû apprendre les gestes du
quotidien
des parents comme les autres
à la différence près que victoire et
Matteo sont tous les deux transgenres
c'est Matteo qui a porté l'enfant né
femme il a conservé ses organes génitaux
féminins afin de concevoir et porter Ava
sa compagne victoire et elle née homme
de la même manière elle n'a pas encore
subi d'opération et ainsi pu concevoir
de façon naturelle son bébé
[Musique]
une situation inédite en France qui a
pris au dépourvu l'administration
on ne savait pas si on pouvait
reconnaître déjà à la base si on pouvait
reconnaître ou pas notre enfant que vous
avez conçu biologiquement
parce que on nous parlait même avec
l'avocate
le couple tente de contacter le
procureur de la République dès le début
de la grossesse pour préparer l'arrivée
d'Ava mais sans succès ils ont eu la
mauvaise surprise de découvrir sur le
livret de famille que leur changement de
genre n'était pas reconnu
donc il est inscrit que victoire et
l'époux ou le père d'Ava et moi Matteo
épouse ou merde et en même temps et en
même temps il est écrit que je suis
aussi le fils de voilà et victoire
écrite c'est la fille de ses parents sur
la même page sur la même page donc sur
la même page je suis homme et femme en
même temps et Matteo est femme et homme
en même temps du coup nous ce qu'on
voudrait c'est que bah moi je suis
reconnu père là-bas et victoire la mer
quoi donc pour que le livret de famille
soit écrit correctement et que la petite
plus tard au niveau de ses documents et
de
pour toute sa vie derrière quoi que ce
soit fait correctement
victoire et Matteo ont pris une avocate
pour les accompagner dans leur combat
ils doivent préparer leur prochain
rendez-vous pour demander une aide
juridictionnelle
donc là c'est la sécu qu'il me faut les
à partir du mois de janvier oui oui
[Musique]
face au silence du législateur sur leur
existence et sur leur réalité
quotidienne les familles transgenres
sont démunis
pour se faire aider victoire se rend
chez son avocate à Bourges
judiciaire de Bourges où l'on va
assigner Monsieur le Procureur en
l'occurrence madame la procureur puisque
la copie intégrale de l'acte de
naissance de Ava peut pas rester comme
elle est puisque
c'est une signée la procureur de la
République de Bourges c'est la prochaine
étape de la procédure elle devra alors
se positionner sur la modification de
l'acte de naissance d'Ava
l'avocate à avant tout à cœur de
défendre les intérêts de l'enfant
des années et des animaux juste 30 ans
si elle va passer un examen et qu'on
demande la copie intégrale de son acte
de naissance si elle a un emploi un
entretien ou quoi que ce soit un
passeport ou un voyage ou je ne sais
quoi avec un moment on demande la copie
intégrale de son acte de naissance je ne
veux pas qu'un tiers ça sache
ce qui relève de notre intimité à nous à
savoir que effectivement nous sommes un
coup tranchant
c'est pas pour rien
victoire l'assure elle n'a pas besoin du
livret de famille pour expliquer à son
rythme la vérité à Ava sur l'identité de
ses parents
cette situation l'inquiète pour l'avenir
de sa fille pour moi s'ils sont livrés
de famille et son acte de naissance sont
pas modifiées elles risquent de
l'apprendre de rien que à l'École etc
j'ai vécu du harcèlement par rapport à
mes camarades j'ai vécu du harcèlement
par rapport à mes professeurs
donc je sais très bien qu'elle peut déjà
en subir en tant qu'individu à part
entière donc j'ai pas envie qu'on lui en
donne encore en plus par rapport à ses
parents alors qu'elle a même pas choisi
ses parents si on peut faire bouger les
choses pour tout le monde c'est encore
plus gratifiant parce que justement nous
on se bat pour notre enfant mais pas que
c'est
c'est peut-être bête à dire mais c'est
limite on se bat pour la petite à 30 40%
et 60 70 % pour les autres en fait parce
que
limite son acte de naissance et son
livret il serait pas modifié et on
pourrait lui expliquer comme nous on en
a envie on le ferait mais on a envie de
se battre aussi pour d'autres qui eux
ont pas la force de se battre le couple
aidé de leur avocate voudrait créer une
jurisprudence Sandrine barré n'hésite
pas à s'appuyer sur les autres
procédures en cours pour des situations
similaires on a des enfants c'est
évident que le combat des inserts le
combat des autres c'est évident que il y
a cette synergie qui est que on a un
client on croit en son combat on
considère qu'on n'est pas dans
l'illégalité ou dans l'immoralité la
plus absolue si on considère que c'est
immoral ou à moral dossier voilà mais
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait avancer de
droit et c'est pas les av ocats les plus
timorés qui ont fait avancer le droit
c'est pas vrai c'est effectivement les
plus combatifs les plus combattants les
plus
à l'écoute je pense de leurs clients de
dire moi je crois en votre combat et le
combat des autres va m'aider aussi donc
on va prendre des claques on va avoir
des victoires qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
claques qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
victoires comment on fait avancer les
choses
une victoire il y en a eu une première
en 2022 dans l'Hérault c'est l'histoire
de Claire née dans le corps d'un homme
et qui décide de changer de sexe à
l'état civil avant sa transition
médicale elle conçoit avec sa compagne
un enfant de façon naturelle après 8 ans
de bataille judiciaire la cour d'appel
de Toulouse a accepté qu'elle soit
reconnue maire sur l'acte de naissance
de l'enfant
un combat mené par une avocate
parisienne installée dans le quartier du
Marais
[Musique]
spécialisé dans le droit des nouvelles
familles Clélia Richard voit les
dossiers s'empiler sur son bureau
ces couples qui rencontrent le même
problème que victoire et Matteo
consultent généralement cet avocate dès
le début de la grossesse
nous les solutions qu'on préconise c'est
lorsqu'un enfant nait et qu'il a deux
parents qui puisse avoir sa filiation
établit à l'égard de ces deux parents
sans procédure judiciaire parce que
Claire ça a duré 8 ans que pour Matteo
victoire je leur souhaite que ce soit
plus court mais enfin ça va quand même
être un peu coton pareil moi pour
d'autres cas qui se présentent
jusqu'en 2016 pour changer de sexe sur
sa carte d'identité il était obligatoire
d'être stérile une loi condamnée par la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
désormais sans l'obligation d'une
opération chirurgicale les personnes
transgenres ont accès à la parentalité
mais rien n'a été prévu pour leurs
enfants leurs actes de naissance restent
alors au bon vouloir des procureurs de
la République pas toujours enclin à
inscrire le nouveau genre des parents
[Musique]
donc derrière ça fait forcément des
saisines de magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire qui se disent ah mon Dieu
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça et qu'est-ce
que j'ai dans la loi ah bah j'ai rien
d'accord bon alors qu'est-ce que j'ai
dans la convention panée droit l'homme
et puis ça vient se heurter aussi à la
norme sociale aux convictions enfin je
veux dire nos magistrats et c'est pas
des cyborgs
pour faire bouger les choses Clélia
Richard est investie dans l'association
des parents et futurs parents gays et
lesbiens aux côtés d'une dizaine
d'avocats mais aussi de chercheurs dans
le but de sensibiliser les
parlementaires et les médias sur la
parentalité transgenre
[Musique]
comment ça va elle doit faire le point
sur les dossiers en cours avec Cléo
caastro membre actif de la commission
le dossier de Bordeaux moi j'attends mon
délibéré
pas très optimiste
très concrètement on part du terrain
donc Clélia à l'avantage de partir des
situations concrètes au tribunal et le
travail avec des personnes qui défend
qui se battent pour qu'on reconnaisse
leurs droits à être parent c'est pas
toujours garanti pour les personnes
trans qui sont discriminées à plusieurs
niveaux et notamment au tribunal lorsque
l'on se retrouve face à des experts qui
ne sont pas formés sur la question à des
avocats des avocats qui peuvent être
très agressifs voir offensif par rapport
aux questions de trans c'est un sujet
très sensible il y a beaucoup de
familles où il y a des parents de France
il y a beaucoup d'enfants qui ont des
parents en France et puisqu'on le pense
et donc l'idée c'est vraiment que tout
le monde puisse suivre sa vie
correctement
[Musique]
ce combat juridique ne sera pas la
première bataille dans la vie de
victoire et Matteo née dans le mauvais
corps ils ont dû très tôt se battre
contre ce mal-être
tu vois là le visage que j'ai triste
tout le temps comme ça
tout le temps il y a pas un moment où je
rigolais où je souriais
jamais tout le temps comme ça et tu
regarderas sur tous tes photos c'est
quasiment tout comme ça merci de leurs
anciennes d'identité ils ont pourtant
conservé des souvenirs
des moments douloureux pour Mathéo qui
s'appelait alors Flora je pense c'était
un peu un appel à l'aide ou quelque
chose comme ça je pense je voulais
montrer ce que cet album là après je
l'avais montré à ma famille j'avais
montré à des amis etc et je pense que
j'ai mis longtemps avant de faire ma
transition j'ai commencé j'avais 24 ans
et là j'étais tout jeune j'avais à 18-19
ans
victoire aussi à un album photo qui date
d'avant sa transition une période de sa
vie où elle répondait encore au nom de
Valentin
ma meilleure amie que je voulais
commencer ma transition
et du coup elle m'avait prêté une robe
son maquillage etc j'ai commencé à
m'habiller au rayon femme à mes 18 ans
opérer une transition de genre et
vouloir concevoir un enfant n'est pas
toujours compatible pour concrétiser
leurs rêves victoire et Matteo ont dû
faire des sacrifices et interrompre leur
transition hormonale
ils ont tous les deux repris leur
traitement
c'est d'ailleurs le prochain sujet que
veut aborder victoire sur les réseaux
sociaux
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer le
traitement hormonal que je prends et
donc j'en mets deux sur la cuisse gauche
2 sur la cuisse droite et ensuite il
faut masser jusqu'à temps que ça
s'imprègne pareil ça je le fais le soir
juste avant de dormir pour que le
cerveau et le temps de tout assimiler
pendant la nuit parce que le cerveau
travaille beaucoup plus la nuit que la
journée
répondre aux médias ou partager son
quotidien de maman transgenres sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est pour victoire une
démarche militante
je veux faire bouger les choses je veux
aider un maximum de personnes et j'ai
beaucoup de personnes justement qui sont
venues me voir
pour me dire que leur transition avait
pas encore réellement commencé parce
qu'ils étaient perdus ils savaient pas
comment faire exactement donc quand
c'est comme ça j'essaye de leur
expliquer
comment moi j'ai fait comment Matteo a
fait
8 ans c'est le temps que pourrait
prendre ce combat juridique pour faire
reconnaître leurs changements de genre
sur l'acte de naissance d'Ava
[Musique]
victoire et Matteo le savent le chemin
sera encore long
au total ce sont plus de 300 familles
qui sont concernées en France par ce
vide législatif
un vide qui devra faire débat au
Parlement pour régler la question de la
filiation transgenre
[Musique]